hey what's going on damn thing I you
know I ordered this stupid part I swear
to god I'm picking it up today
god damn it let me hold it onto it like
a terrorist for the last time hey what's
going on it's bill bird it's time for
the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday
Monday morning podcast and I'm just
checking in on you
how the [ __ ] was your goddamn Christmas
why is this wire all [ __ ] up is the
abilities for wires to just get off
[ __ ] how do you look at it it's like
how did that happen how the [ __ ] did
this whole [ __ ] thing go down like
this the headphone better cuz I'm losing
my [ __ ] does that make you feel better
about your [ __ ] cubicle dwelling
[ __ ] lie well I hope it does hope it
does cause I'm all about the positive
vibes in the tutu the one nizzy 2019
how are you did you have
a merry little Christmas did you get
through it without arguing I forgot to
give you guys that pep top don't take
the [ __ ] bait all right one of you
have siblings is a trump supporter or
they're a [ __ ] liberal Larry or
they're a centrist centrist Susan you
know her never picked the side Jesus
Christ only [ __ ] person I know could
meet a serial killer and be like well I
guess I can understand why you need to
feed oh yeah really talk to me when you
end up in a trunk Susan there's no
reason to do that there's no reason to
do it because you're not gonna get what
you want which is the satisfaction of
the other person going oh my god I never
realized how right you are
it wasn't until you called me a
closed-minded [ __ ]
that I just stopped and paused and was
like wait a minute am i I close my eyes
I am i close my you're a [ __ ] you
would [ __ ] believe what can you tell
me a closed Mary [ __ ] hair yeah on
Christmas it's like Hello
calling your stocking much you know what
I [ __ ] can't stand I can't stand when
Newspeak comes out there I get it back
in the day you know when we were cavemen
walking around doing that [ __ ] you know
you had to come up with some [ __ ]
words so you wouldn't like be asking for
you know some water but yet sound like
you were jerking off uh-huh Manson
oysters I make that's why I do it my
garage
don't want to bother anybody no and I
also understand it if something new
comes along you know like an iPod what
were you supposed to call it a little
stereo I don't [ __ ] know right I
understand those were I just hate when
new [ __ ] words come around and then
everybody just starts [ __ ] saying
them
it drives me up the [ __ ] well
especially like on Twitter when there's
the new or Instagram and they just come
and they go remember they for a while
like when you posted something someone
will just go this you know and then with
what some other that's stupid [ __ ] out
there I can't [ __ ] stand just drives
me it's so [ __ ] unoriginal I just had
somebody give me [ __ ] saying something I
tweeted wasn't funny and they used a gif
it's and I brought the guy back at least
I'm [ __ ] write my own jokes you
[ __ ] hack someone had to like [ __ ]
think of a funny response to my unfunny
joke for you with a little video on it
and now you feel like you're clever
I just drives me what the [ __ ] you know
I just got back into working out right
[ __ ] if I hear one more [ __ ] you
know because I got those those TRX bands
all right if I hear one more douche tell
me that I'm engaging my core you mean
working my abs your fake tan [ __ ] what's
great about these is you're always a
little off-balance er always engaging
your core you don't board a plane
anymore you expedite the boarding
process do you guys could I'd put your
jacket to the overhead compartment so we
could expedite the boarding process
trying to sound like you have a [ __ ]
law degree you're on here for one
[ __ ] reason only that's for cheap
airfare stop acting like it was a dream
I like to wear uniform I like to
expedite the boarding process while
engaging my core this hashtag shaking my
head let me ask you [ __ ] Twitter
[ __ ] a question how many times have you
hashtag shaking my head and you actually
were shaking your head I kept trying to
the last time I [ __ ] shook my head
actually probably do it a lot it's fun
when I try to keep my my [ __ ] cool
long driving this [ __ ] guy
Oh Mike these [ __ ] [ __ ] out here
on the highways the way they pass you on
the right-hand side it's unbelievable
you can get into the left lane doing
like 40 miles an hour you want to get
off the highway you got to be doing like
120 and you watch them passing you an 80
and you look in their Lane and there's a
guy 1/4 mile away and they gonna have to
stomp on the [ __ ] brakes I think it's
just psychologically psychological out
of here that there's so much traffic
that you just think to yourself like you
know anytime there's an open space
you're like yeah just [ __ ] floor it
or maybe I'm just that douche who has
like the baby on board sign in his head
I have no idea but speaking of cars my
latest obsession if I was gonna buy a
car right now alright if I was a single
man if I didn't have a child if I had a
full head of hair to flow in the breeze
I would get the Porsche Targa the fast
one alright in lava orange just like my
peers because I am a child of the 70s
and remember that [ __ ] in Boogie Nights
when Philip Seymour Hoffman rest his
soul he's talking to Mark Wahlberg's
character and he says how the Corvette
is in competition Orange
that was my favorite [ __ ] detail 70s
detail competition orange oh he did wait
he didn't have one he had he had a oh no
Mark Wahlberg's character got
the Corvette in competition orange and
then Philip Seymour Hoffman showed up
with like a Datsun 240z or something
it's still a decent car right um but
it's a it's no Corvette anyways I got to
see what that looks like because I hope
it's not a red orange I'd want an orange
orange you know there's a lot of things
right now it's just like I don't know
everybody's got to start [ __ ] with
the colors but that thing and it's got
the automatic [ __ ] rooftop
there was actually Porsche enthusiasts
who were engaging their core when they
press the [ __ ] send button on the
youtube comment we're complaining
actually complaining the old one you did
yeah he had to do it by hand and then
fold up the cloth top and then put it in
the bonnet as they say overseas put it
under the [ __ ] hood now this one you
just push a button the back end lifts up
a little bit and then the top [ __ ]
goes down like that it's it's it's a
[ __ ] work of art and there's all these
[ __ ] writing like leave it to the
Germans to take something really simple
and make it a [ __ ] and what make it
[ __ ] perfect
someone's ago I would be concerned if I
there was somebody could buy it behind
me that comes a good two feet up behind
the car well they [ __ ] pull up I'll
put make make the tires do one rotation
and then push your button I'm amazed
that when they designed this are you
amazed the [ __ ] you ever designed uh
why am I in such a mood you know I just
I had a bad night's sleep I had this
dream that I was blow is playing the
will theater in Boston Massachusetts one
of my favorite promoters out there bill
bloom and Reich he was in my dream
and he was talking the way he talks
going right bro I saw that article they
wrote about your would you you really
said some mean things about me I was
like we talking about I would never say
mean things about you I loved your
garage just Connor Connor came off a
little mean
so I felt like an [ __ ] like however I
was joking about him somebody it came
off his [ __ ] main Scientology's to
him and then I go out on stage this was
a stress dream because I hadn't been on
stage in like five [ __ ] days and I
got this European tour coming up so I
just booked myself at the Comedy Store
starting last night right through Sunday
just gonna do as much stage time as I
can and I had a great set last night I
don't know it's just I think you know I
just know I got a [ __ ] I need to do
all these nights and then I'll then I'll
be fine when I go to Europe or whatever
so I go out on stage in my dream on the
Wilbert theater and if for some reason
it's like six stories in the air six
stories up and there's people way down
below who clearly can't see me and I
feel like I have to walk to the edge of
the stage but I don't want to fall down
and I'm making fun of it and nobody's
laughing I'm just bombing and for some
reason I'm on I level with the six
storey balcony level and they're just
staring at me and I'm not doing well and
then halfway through my set and there's
all these obstructions to like I'm
walking and all of a sudden like behind
some giant pole and nobody's laughing
and I'm like oh my god what the [ __ ] am
i doing and at one point I was laying
down on the stage crawling towards the
edge because it was also really dark and
I couldn't see how deep it went down
I dropped the mic down there somebody
turned on a record player and I shut it
off and it was just like hey little
Mongoose you know it slowed down wasn't
that song I don't know why I just picked
that maybe because I'm a dancing monkey
on stage I have no [ __ ] idea and then
halfway through it one of the few comics
that I don't like in this business came
[ __ ] walking out like the selfish
[ __ ] that he or she is and picked up
like a little square fridge that you'd
have they when you lived in like a
studio apartment and I was like really
and the person was like yeah really and
they just [ __ ] took it started
walking on I said I said the person's
name I
said from the bottom of my heart I
[ __ ] hate you and then I quickly shut
up because I knew everybody in the crowd
was gonna film it and what's funny is I
don't really hate this person in real
life I just [ __ ] avoid him you know
that's what a great thing about getting
older is you stop hating people you just
sort of like you avoid them even if
you're sitting next to him you just
mentally avoid them you just like okay I
know who you are I know how you act and
this is what I expect so I'm not gonna
get upset I'm just [ __ ] not gonna
engage in it you know and and then
somewhere along the line they turned the
lights on and I realized that I wasn't
six stories in the air that the stage
was still the same height it usually was
and then all of a sudden the microphone
worked and I could start you know doing
my job and I started killing again
so maybe the dream was Bill you have an
irrational fear about taking four or
five days off from stand-up I will tell
you last night I [ __ ] I went onstage
and I got this new Bush Michelle Obama
bit that was bombing you know cause
she's so [ __ ] precious you know I
mean I don't I don't know why out of all
the first lady's every first lady has
always been made fun of her for some
[ __ ] reason he's like off limits so
you know as a comedian something is off
limits I mean you know you kind of have
to steer the ship towards it at one
point just just for the fun of it right
so last night was the first night I
started to get it I started to get it to
work and I tried another bit you know
about this this gay kid you know parents
didn't know she was gay and the parents
like it was [ __ ] people to think he
can pray away being gay
what can you pray away oh I went to
church by the way I got there late you
know I felt bad I got there register the
[ __ ] guy was starting his homily and
I was like oh [ __ ] and then part of me
was psyched because I didn't have to sit
through the first two readings
and they really switched up the words a
lot the [ __ ] that you say they switched
it up a lot I was like is this like some
West Coast thing my mother-in-law is
like now they kind of changed it up you
know used to be peace be with you and
also with you
they like added a bunch of words like
peace be with you and I I concurred that
also and would wish that upon you - sir
/ ma'am you gonna say all that before
you should [ __ ] shake hands with
somebody I don't know I had been in
church in awhile I literally thought my
suit was gonna catch on fire when I
walked in there it's when you know
you're a piece of [ __ ] you know you
haven't been there in a while you just
walk in and you're just thinking of all
the [ __ ] God would be saying to you if
you really exists you just walking and
going I know I know you know and then
after a while you get stubborn and be
like well you know dude you know
technically you made me so whatever my
[ __ ] flaws are I know you have this
convenient excuse of the devil you know
what I mean I mean what the [ __ ]
hey you know I made you perfect but you
listen to the devil well didn't you make
the devil too isn't all of this your
[ __ ] grand scheme right I actually
went to look at God that way right if he
existed you know and it is a he okay cuz
at the end of the day you know when you
really look at the world most of the
great things that were created we're
done by men and I don't know why I have
to shy away from that and this
progressive but you know ladies why
don't you put your [ __ ] brains will
your mouth die and [ __ ] start
inventing some [ __ ] and I know you're
gonna come at me with this [ __ ] list
that that is impressive to you but what
I also want you to Google my feminist
little friends is what have men invented
and you watch that [ __ ] there it's
[ __ ] Dan Marino nineteen eighty-four
forty eight touchdowns fifty-eight
hundred [ __ ] yards when you could
still beat the [ __ ] out of a wide wrist
and a quarterback having said that I
love it and I feel you're very brave
anytime you put on your lab coat and sit
down to make a new widget it's so much
I'm just trying to make sure I have it
all down just someday I would like to
host an award show and I have to make
sure that I'm the [ __ ] zombie that
they're looking for I'll do I'll come
out do a monologue just talking about
how dumb men are and how we can't even
figure out how to dress ourselves
without women you know all of that [ __ ]
and they'll just [ __ ] eat it up
that's another thing I [ __ ] hate you
know what I hate I hate when a running
back gets like [ __ ] 40 carries and he
has like 47 yards and then he finally
breaks one for about 15 and then he gets
up and he does that um eating a bowl of
oatmeal thing it's like buddy we've been
feeding you the [ __ ] ball all goddamn
game once you go look at your [ __ ]
yardage average your 2.7 yards per carry
[ __ ] hey Bill
how about something positive all right I
got something positive for you I watched
this [ __ ] Celtics first the
Philadelphia 76er you know [ __ ] blew
me away in that game is that Joelle
Joelle and Beebe how do you say his name
I'm not looking it up because I can't
spell it evidently that guy played
soccer a football as they call it over
the over the [ __ ] seas there until
late in his life I got to tell you
something that guy is like a ridiculous
factor when he's on the court and I know
he's one of the guys in the league but I
don't think I don't think he's getting
the respect he deserves that [ __ ] guy
is a problem on both ends of the court
blocking shots getting rebounds scoring
points [ __ ] assists moves great for a
big man I am praying to the basketball
gods look at me I'm going to church I'm
[ __ ] all about every God out there
now I can't you feel the joy that's
coming back into my my life
it's like the end of the Grinch isn't it
I am praying to the basketball gods that
the the that the Celtics and 76ers are
gonna [ __ ] play again I don't even
care if we lose that's how much I enjoy
that playoff series from back in the day
when I used to watch Andrew Tony and dr.
J Bobby Jones Billy Cunningham all those
[ __ ] coming in town Darryl
Dawkins the first time through and then
it was Moses anyways the [ __ ] was I just
gonna talk about oh I remember oh so I'm
reading this book on Bob Cousy and Bill
Russell called the last pass
does that really count as reading by the
way to read about sports I don't think
it does it's like a long sports page as
far as I'm concerned I don't know if I
brought this up right I forget but like
for the longest time I thought that the
first NBA basketball player with the
sneaker deal was Michael Jordan now he
might have had what his name on the
sneaker but then I found out that those
red and white converse were called the
dr. J's but I don't remember them having
his name on it initially so then I'm
reading this book and I find out that
Bob Cousy in likes 1962 or 63 had his
own sneaker he signed a deal with PF
Flyers and it looks like a bootleg Chuck
Taylor and I found a pair on on [ __ ]
eBay for a hundred and fifty five bucks
I didn't buy him but cuz I'm not a
sneaker head yo y'all you see the do
Jordan 48 what are they up to by the way
what are they up to
it is amazing that 30 years has gone by
he must have a new sneaker every year I
would say they're on the Jordan 32 let's
look this well let's finish this story
so Bob Cousy that's the one I want you
know I'm kind of fascinated by that
whole
[Music]
sneaker culture as far as like you know
all the different like do you get the
sedale three fours or whatever you know
Jordans 2019 let's see what they got
coming up what do they got in the in in
in the [ __ ] sneaker barrel air jordan
one retro sample it was a sample so
that's not exactly what they came out
with and they want $4,000 for those are
you [ __ ] kidding me what do you do
how do what do you sneak a head so you
put them on the wall so you feel like
you're always in a footlocker Air Jordan
released 2018 all right let's see what
are they up to here Air Jordan 12 how
the [ __ ] are they only on the 12th
alright Air Jordan 9 third verse he sent
me a text the other day was [ __ ]
hilarious he's like dude Jordan three
mocha [ __ ] over and it was the Jordan
threes with this mocha color cement
thing and I [ __ ] died laughing I mean
he's like jeez like that [ __ ] chick
there with the thin head Sarah Jessica
Parker on Sex in the City
except rather than talking about [ __ ]
high heels he's talking about sneakers
anyway so Bob Cousy had a pair of PF
Flyers and you know what this with a
little circle is on the Chuck Taylor it
was his face and it said Bob Cousy on it
and they were black and they had a
little green trim on him so that's his
far back for all you [ __ ] sneaker
heads there I know Kareem abdul-jabbar
he had his own did he have his own
sneaker at UCLA low-top edita I don't
know but who was like the first guy
actually had like his name on it though
because I think maybe the technically
the dr. J converse just said were just
nicknamed the dr. J's but they said
converse let me look that up dr. J
converse see this is why I like talking
[ __ ] about things because then I
getting into it like [ __ ] the primp
the Premier League all right let's see
here
yeah those are the classic classic
converse all-stars I don't see his name
on it oh and then eventually they did
but the original one one of the cleanest
[ __ ] shoes ever that for some reason
I think the newer one said when I was a
kid they didn't say dr. J on him and now
I'm looking at a really old pair and
those ones say dr. J so I think after a
while they said dr. J and those things
look like they came up before the Air
Jordan but as far as I can tell the Bob
[ __ ] cozy the koozie ones do those
somebody [ __ ] way back there Kuji
ones with a pork pie hat [ __ ] over
she all right let me look at some stuff
here I missed the last two Liverpool
games I got all wrapped up in the
holidays and I cannot [ __ ] believe
this
I don't know anything about the
Wolverhampton Wanderers
but somehow we lost to him we beat
Newcastle United for two nothing but the
[ __ ] wolves these guys don't even
look like they're there
there's nothing premier about their
their uniform their [ __ ] name or
anything what happened Muhammad Salla
and Virgil Vantage struck to claim
oh no they won wait a minute that
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
that doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
because we beat Manchester United three
two one and it says three two one and
then it says [ __ ] zero two so I guess
they do that all because that was an
away game ah yeah cheeky [ __ ] alright I
learned something else that's how they
do it okay so they got arson a one-nil
Arsenal coming up the only one the only
Premier League game I've ever been to
I told you they played Everton it's
[ __ ] hilarious and they went up one
to nothing they started singing one nil
Arsenal and halfway through the [ __ ]
song Everton scored and this little blue
puff of smoke came up the 40 Everton
fans were going [ __ ] nuts and all the
Arsenal people had to shut the [ __ ] up I
love when that happens
I was watching a ranger game earlier
this year and [ __ ] as always Henrik
Lundqvist was playing unbelievable and
the whole garden is going Henrik
Lundqvist Henrik Lundqvist or whatever
as they're chanting that the other team
[ __ ] scored that's what you get
alright let's look at some Google News
here we'll start with the greatest
country in America the United States of
America alright after Trump visits Iraq
lawmakers demand US withdrawal finally
let's get the [ __ ] out of their way
we're going bankrupt Iraqi lawmakers
demand us withdraw Baghdad Iraqi
lawmakers this is the greatest thing
that could [ __ ] happen to us if we
combine it with solar power in electric
cars alright you gotta hit him where it
hurts just like the feminists do the
feminists go after the money they go
after the advertisers this is what the
[ __ ] you got to do in the Middle East
alright truly the great thing though as
if we pull out I believe they'll just go
back unfortunately because I don't have
a problem with Middle Eastern people I
do
a problem with [ __ ] okay and [ __ ]
they're everywhere
right as long as you're not a [ __ ] I
don't have a problem with you so I think
that they'll go back to trying to
[ __ ] you know deal with each other
hopefully not in a violent way but you
know it's gonna be but I always looked
at it like the way when Russia withdrew
from [ __ ] Europe everybody was like
okay where were we and they just picked
up with their fights again it's really
perfect for the life of me I'll never
understand how war is legal you know
we're sitting here like working on
gender-neutral bathrooms while war is
still legal it means just [ __ ] nuts
are you don't ease I think it's cuz they
they keep updating the war of the the
weapons so it seems modern you know but
if you still went out there like the
Braveheart days and there was you know
two people standing on opposing Hills
and then they just ran down the hill
yelling and they just [ __ ] met in the
valley and they had those sticks with
the [ __ ] uh the [ __ ] cannon ball
with the spikes coming out of it you
know basically you dress like a Raider
fan except you can actually hurt
somebody you don't have the rubber
points you wouldn't want to put
somebody's eye out when you're
intimidating somebody Raider fans
alright so politicians from both blocks
of Iraq's divided parliament called for
a vote to expel US troops and promised
to schedule an extraordinary session to
debate the matter parlor I like that
they've taken control their country
again Parliament must clearly and
urgently express its view about the
ongoing American violations of Iraq's
sovereignty said Salaam I'll sure marry
a lawmaker loyal to the populist cleric
moqtada al-sadr through the [ __ ]
balls you have over there to be any sort
of a leader man I mean you're really I
mean I hope what they're doing over
there works because what we're doing is
not stopping terrorism
maybe it's stopping it from coming over
here I I don't [ __ ] know but
all I know is when I look at the ledger
you know we're [ __ ] bankrupt we just
keep raising our amount of debt why
don't we [ __ ] them good back here
get back here bring the [ __ ] kids
home
alright [ __ ] get on get into this
electrical [ __ ] I think of a [ __ ] if it
hurts the environment more just think so
we can pay this [ __ ] off alright with
the money we make from exporting all the
weed that we're growing now goddamn it
if I can figure out how to solve the
world's problems can't somebody in a
suit and tie do it alright let's see
what's going on in Germany that's my
first stop Germany army could recruit EU
citizens wow [ __ ] sakes it just Jeremy
they really doing this again alright
slowly loading slowly slowly loading it
is really bizarre how Europe if they're
not unified they just they just [ __ ]
they will start a World War you know and
then what do we get we get [ __ ] for
boredom what's the worst thing we do we
get fat is that all we're doing no bill
I think you're doing a little more than
that in the world that right all right
German army could recruit EU citizens
seven years after Germany's scrapped
conscription whatever the [ __ ] that it
its Defense chief has said employing EU
citizens is an option to fill expert
posts army general inspector Eber hard
Zorn said the forces had to lock head oh
sorry luck look in all direction in
times of lack of qualified personnel
such as doctors and IT specialists oh
wow have they outsourced all this [ __ ]
in their country to the armed forces
have been beset by years of
underinvestment Germany aims to increase
its military by 21,000 personnel by 2025
well what the [ __ ] are they getting
ready for yeah Jesus Christ
you know this is why you don't read
world news this is why you just sit
around and you try and find a new sport
that you can get involved in all right
let me let me do the one read here for
this week all right
and by the way my little thing for my
headphones came I just have to go pick
it up all right let's get over here by
the way made it through Christmas what's
up without boozing 33 [ __ ] days in 33
days in I'm gonna go to the Rose Bowl
sober and then I'm gonna go on my tour
and I am gonna be [ __ ] ready baby
butcher box everybody butcher box
delivers healthy 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken and heritage bread pork the
greatest pork chop I've ever cooked the
incredible quality of butcher box meat
starts with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones they rub their bellies
before they murder them cook with the
peace of mind knowing you're eating
holiday high-quality meat grass-fed and
grass finished products these aren't
pigs eating other [ __ ] pigs like the
goddamn animals in this country the hell
see it's choice you can make for your
family each box comes with at least
eight to 11 pounds of meat meat which is
enough for 24 individual size meals you
can choose from five different box types
all beef all right I'll be for the
racist beef and chicken for somebody
every once in a while will bang somebody
outside their race beef and pork
old-school mix box for the liberal
custom box for the Dean Delray right
Dean Delray likes all this [ __ ] custom
lets you choose your own cuts for free
bacon and $20 off your first box go to
butcher box com
slash / and enter promo code birbee URR
alright that's the podcast for this week
god bless awliya
have a great weekend you [ __ ] I'll see
on Monday and uh I guess that's it you
know try to get along with each other
everyone all right I'll see you
shame
I'll be brave
[Music]
how we take each other's love
I think
[Music]
something
[Music]
[Music]
don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday December 27th 2010 the final
Monday of 2010 huh what are you gonna do
with it huh are you gonna make this the
greatest Monday he'll likely hate one of
those [ __ ] motivational speakers
you're sitting there you're trying to
get motivated to not be a negative [ __ ]
like myself right and then this guy
comes out you get me getting all excited
to [ __ ] have something positive be
said to you and what does the guy do he
keep makes he gets you all nervous with
this [ __ ] ridiculous heightened sense
of urgency for just a regular [ __ ]
day this is Monday think about that
everybody this is Monday December 27th
2010
does anybody know what that means well I
mean there's no history I don't say hey
that's the worst part - and they start
acting like somebody else talk to them
well John there's no historical uh uh
thingamajig for December 27th this is
just a regular day think about that
everybody it's just a regular day
if this just a regular shirt am I just a
regular person is that how I'm gonna
live my life right there
[ __ ] BAM blow his [ __ ] brains up
right there see it wasn't a regular
Monday you [ __ ] douche it was a
Monday you died because no one wants to
hear your [ __ ] speech all right I think
I've said [ __ ] 58 times already anyways
it's December 27th two days after
Christmas 72 [ __ ] days and to
me not drinking I can eat five more days
no four more days and I break my record
for uh you know being sober I'm going
for a hundred days and it's good it's
going good
oh yeah I'm having a great [ __ ] time
oh Jesus anyways did you guys have
yourself a merry little Christmas do you
have a good Christmas did you get the
things that you wanted
I had a [ __ ] awesome Christmas once I
was able to finally relax cuz people out
there who do the road truckers other
comedians lounge singers actually lounge
singers don't travel they just stuck at
that same [ __ ] place you know
like Jack Nicholson and the movie The
Shining just slowly going [ __ ] crazy
playing handball off the wall of their
Red Roof Inn [ __ ] sweet yeah when you
travel as much as I do your brain I
don't know it can't slow down it needs
like four or five days to slow down and
you can't sit down on a couch and lay
down on a bed for like at least I can't
for like more than 10 minutes your brain
is just [ __ ] go and go and go and go
and going and it took me like four or
five days and then I was finally able to
relax and in and enjoy the holiday I
actually I was so wound up from doing
the road I actually wanted to be wanted
to be alone
I'd even though I didn't want to be
alone it's Christmas I don't want to be
alone but I did I just didn't want to
deal with any sort of people and I've
discovered when you become an adult
truly become an adult his Christmas is
not about you anymore it's about making
sure everyone around you had a great
Christmas and then after all the frenzy
is sitting back and your enjoyment is
that everyone around you had a great
Christmas and I finally figured that out
this year and I became a jolly
son-of-a-bitch
I really enjoyed my Christmas you know
and I gotta admit on December 26
yesterday I went out and bought
something that I wanted I'm gradually
putting together a John Bonham [ __ ] I
don't know if I'm going it out as as him
on Halloween or if I'm [ __ ] gonna
make a stupid YouTube video I don't know
what but I'm gradually putting together
[ __ ] that looks like stuff that he wore
and I can grow a beard I'll die at Brown
we'll see what happens
you know what I bought I bought his
Adidas sneakers that he wore at the the
Seattle concert and you know you're a
[ __ ] John Bonham freak for those of
you weren't into music John Bonham is
the greatest [ __ ] drummer I ever
heard you know just as far as the [ __ ]
that I like I know you can say of Max
Roach and all those [ __ ] guys Buddy
Rich I'm not trying to be a dick here
alright but except for the [ __ ] who
think Neil Peart is better than John
Bonham alright and and if you think that
you are a monotone jackass alright but
anyways yeah if you go on YouTube and
you look up it's actually Moby Dick rare
clip and it's him in Seattle at that
point they weren't calling it Moby Dick
anymore they were calling it something I
guess over the top cuz Robert Plant goes
John Henry Bonham over the top and then
they got like this just
1970s what is it [ __ ] technology
where it goes over the top top wait you
know it's supposed to be like blowing
people's minds if you look at the
arrogant way Robert Plant walks away
from the mic you really want to throw
something at the back of his bushy head
but if you watch John Bonham play he's
got a pair of I believe the adidas
dragons huh anybody old out there
remember that Dita's Dragons adidas
country the adidas dragon so I have
those and all I need is a pair of white
[ __ ] pants and they sell a replica
that t-shirt that he wore in the song
remains the same so right there I got
the [ __ ] outfit then I got to do is
just get a wig and I'm good to go uh
maybe I'll do that for you guys next
year I'll make a [ __ ] oh you know
it'll be a riot I should do that and not
say it's me and I'll just put a youtube
video up and it'll be John Bonham cover
and I'll butcher one of his songs and
you guys can all laugh at how bad people
trash me for actually buying the entire
outfit I'm not above it dude I am a
total [ __ ] music geek like that I
will actually buy something speaking of
that I want to recommend a book here
before I am I don't know if I've even
said anything funny other than revealing
how [ __ ] pathetic my personal life is
what do I got here out of all the Led
Zeppelin books out there and there's a
zillion of them and they're all [ __ ]
ridiculous for the most part they always
have them selling their soul to the
devil and Jimmy Page muttering some sort
of a cult [ __ ] walking away you know
of them [ __ ] sticking a flounder and
some girl's [ __ ] which probably happened
to Seattle I have no [ __ ] idea but
the best book that I have found on it is
it's called John Bonham the powerhouse
behind Led Zeppelin and it's written by
his brother Mick Bonham and it says
right on the back or is it on the inside
cover why he wrote the book he basically
says if I can just paraphrase here why
don't I just read you a little excerpt
about ten years ago this is from his
brother
after Oh actually Linda Bonham wrote
this about ten years ago after reading
yet another load of rubbish about his
brother John my husband Mick turned to
me and said I should write a book about
our kid if only to tells Oh John's
daughter what a great bloke her dad was
and with that the seeds of this book
began to grow and it's it's [ __ ] it's
it's just a killer book it's very very
little of it is actually about you know
all the [ __ ] that those other books
are about which is you know then they
went to this town and they drank this
much and they did this and they did that
it's it's really him growing up with
John and John being home in between the
tours and it's [ __ ] awesome I read it
in like a day and a half two days but
when do you expect that considering I
basically exposed myself to be like that
chick who whacks Selina you know you
know that [ __ ] psycho
Jesus Christ if John Bonham was alive
would I be stalking him this is really
getting creepy alright let's let's
[ __ ] plow ahead a but I want to
recommend that book all right in there's
big words and lots of pages by big words
I mean big font lots of pictures and
yeah definitely check it out definitely
check it out and classic Englishman I
could tell you that about John Bonham in
that like most Englishman he looks like
he never lifted a weight in his life got
that awful fish-and-chip torso yet
continued to wear tight shirts right
through this career never understand
that you only see that you don't you do
not see that here in America except with
gay guys gay guys will wear tight shirts
no matter what shape they're in that's
not true they will actually if long as
they got a little peck action going on
they don't give a [ __ ] about this
stomach you know that as long as that
chest is out a little bit further than
the stomach they wear tight shirts too
but I've been over to Europe and I'm
telling you I've never seen it like you
can never did a push-up and their
[ __ ] lives those types of bodies you
got that seventh grade chest and arms
and then this [ __ ]
I just drank a keg of beer stomach and
this you know this is like you know what
it is this is like they made it big
before Elvis [ __ ] died and Elvis is
the first behind the music as far as the
rock star and all that I know everything
I stole all the music from the blues and
gospel black dudes you know what go [ __ ]
yourself
I'm so sick of that stupid-ass [ __ ]
argument he didn't he was influenced by
him but because he's a different race
they said he stole it it's such [ __ ]
you know if you're black and you listen
to a blues guy and you play blues good
you're carrying on a tradition but if
you're white you do it you're stealing
alright and if black dudes [ __ ] steal
white music they're sampling it's
[ __ ] it's all [ __ ] nobody's
stealing from anybody you're you're
being influenced so enough already with
the [ __ ] whining I'm so sick of
[ __ ] people bitching that this unfair
business is unfair yes show business is
unfair if life is unfair oh really did
you write it and then you didn't get
credit well [ __ ] welcome to the club I
never wrote anything that he can get
credit for but I can tell you right now
I have been a victim of some very
creative math yeah you know what bill
here's your royalty checks that's four
dollars and 98 cents yeah we had a
hundred grand worth of white out that we
and we had to buy a new typewriter that
cost us 30 grand you know and all that
comes out of your [ __ ] pocket yeah
it's been going on forever but the
reason why I say Elvis is the original
behind the music is because he's the
first guy who got as far as I can tell
got lofted all the way up into the
stratosphere and like everything he did
now is just so [ __ ] cliche but he was
the first guy doing it so nobody could
really see it you know and by the time
he died as a drug drug-addicted fat [ __ ]
on a toilet that was 77 you know at
which point you know Zeppelin was
approaching 30 years of aid they they
were it was already too late right does
that make any [ __ ] sense I'm trying
to I'm trying to justify and this is
also before like John Bonham never
got that if peoples living today I can I
can't guarantee they wouldn't be dead
but he definitely would have like a 95%
chance of not being dead because someone
would be like you know say you had a
problem that'd be an intervention and
then also when he got out of shape and
he started getting the man tits there
they they they [ __ ] he would've got
the [ __ ] teased out of him on YouTube
and just out of sheer [ __ ] humiliation
I think he would have done some sit-ups
but you never know he is European and
they just really don't seem to be into
physical fitness over there this is
coming from an American they're not
obese but they are just some fleshy
mushy sons of [ __ ] over there not all
of them not all you get your occasional
one but though the occasional one seems
like the ones that are born that way you
know like their dad was like a [ __ ]
shipbuilder and his dad was they no
[ __ ] work with Thor or some [ __ ] you
know what I mean I don't [ __ ] now
what am I talking about here really
people huh 13 minutes of absolute [ __ ]
all right that's what I'm what are we
gonna talk about this week here oh you
guys wanna hear a story guys one here
story here do you got yep Jake do you
actually have to work right now does
anybody know is anybody working right
now does anybody have such a [ __ ]
dick for a boss that he basically gave
you New Year's Eve off and then
Christmas Day off and now it's Monday
now you're back to work you know this is
it really I don't know about you guys
this is one of the most depressing weeks
of the year you know is the week between
Christmas and New Year's once Christmas
is over
you know it's like you see the build up
of the tree first of all you get your
Christmas tree and if you're like me
everybody trashes the tree except for
this guy here who writes me this letter
hey Bill [ __ ] the haters [ __ ] the haters
your tree is awesome
your tree is a noble fir which is a far
superior tree compared to those [ __ ]
Douglas firs I love this guy immediately
just those trees are gay anyways where
the hell am i yes they look a little
sparse but there is actually room to
hang the ornaments I like to joke that
most people decorate their Christmas
bushes by just throwing [ __ ] at them and
hoping for the best ever notice all the
ends of the branches of Douglas firs are
freshly cut Douglas firs do not grow in
a conical shape that means Christmas
tree shape I guess they have to be
trimmed in order to look like a tree
because they normally look like a bush
exactly that's why I never like those
[ __ ] trees it looks like a shrub I've
never seen a [ __ ] tree look like a
Christmas tree that's why and that's why
I like the tree that I bought because it
looked like a [ __ ] tree thank you sir
he said have you ever seen how they
prune these trees on the farm before
they're shipped to your local grocery
store parking lot a dude would dude with
the hedge clipper tied to his back and
an angle goes up and down the rows of
bushes and walks around each one cutting
it into a Christmas tree shape Nobles
aren't artificially shaped at all and
grow to be symmetrical and perfectly
proportioned there you go so go [ __ ]
yourselves I also had somebody else
write me a letter saying [ __ ] all those
people my my sister or somebody is
[ __ ] what she saved it isn't in our
some sort of artistic design or
something too like my Theresa you know
what I'm a little head of the curve
people you wait you know what's gonna
happen one of these [ __ ] emaciated
celebrities is gonna get one then it's
gonna become all the rage thing we
wearing Uggs with the [ __ ] Santa
Claus thong right with the midriff
showing be like oh my god like oh my god
it's a is like oh my god and they're
gonna be in US magazine and that's gonna
be it Matthew McConaughey will be naked
playing bongos and it all worked out but
you will remember
that you heard it here first uh-huh you
heard it here first I actually bought a
[ __ ] tree you guys bought shrubs
all right so [ __ ] you and your holiday
but anyways yeah it's a really
depressing week so anyways you go out
you buy the goddamn tree so then you
have the tree and there's the excitement
of the smell of the tree it smells like
Christmas oh my god it's gonna happen
right it's that time of year we're gonna
actually get off the wheel for a second
joy the people around us hopefully you
know and then what happened you decorate
the tree you put a little skirt around
it you dress up that little [ __ ] right
you're getting even more excited that
what happened you come home from work
and one of your family members of the
person you live with has wrapped a
couple of gifts putting it underneath
this is the build up right this is Elvis
1954 right before he [ __ ] hit you
know and then what happens a couple more
gifts somebody puts on a [ __ ]
Christmas record your balls are filled
up just waitin to [ __ ] for Christmas
day and then Christmas comes alright
Elvis on the [ __ ] Ed Sullivan Show
everybody's going [ __ ] crazy people
open and gifts this [ __ ] [ __ ]
screaming outside your window you throw
down a scarf at him everything is
[ __ ] great and then just like that
it's over it's [ __ ] over
you know you get drafted send you over
to Germany I can't do this Elvis thing I
don't [ __ ] know I'm sayin here you
know what I mean Dennis [ __ ] over
then you looking at your tree you know
it still got the lights it still has the
skirt for what happened to all the gifts
they're all gone you know couple of
pieces of paper it's like they peaked
it's like your favorite band they had
those three awesome albums in a row and
now they're about ready to [ __ ] spend
their rest of their career trying to
recapture those the the the whatever the
[ __ ] they did in those three albums
right
that's it it's over say goodbye to
everybody start looking at your family
members you see them they're a year
older which makes you feel older yeah
nothing's on TV all the TV people are on
vacation that's showing something on a
loop MTV's finally showing [ __ ] videos
it gets quiet you sit back you reflect
on what a nice Christmas it is but you
just can't get over this feeling of this
wave of depression that's coming because
you know it's about ready to start all
over again another [ __ ] year with
this [ __ ] job with that [ __ ]
douche telling me what to do my [ __ ]
boyfriend your [ __ ] girlfriend your
wifey a husband it's gonna be another
[ __ ] year you know that's your
[ __ ] tree just reminding you of your
goddamn mortality cuz you're not you're
not you're not [ __ ] watering it the
way you watered it before Christmas you
skip a few days branches start to droop
couples start to turn brown like the
gray in your hair look at this artistic
little jaunt I'm on here
you know it by the tight-end it what's
the worst is then you start walking down
the street going out to your car and
what happens the body start piling up
out there you see your first [ __ ]
Christmas tree that bah humbug douche
bag across the street who throws the
[ __ ] thing out at like 1 o'clock in
the morning December 26th it's sitting
out there right lay it on its side
like a [ __ ] victim at the beginning
of the first 48 you know it's got one
little piece of tinsel blowing in the
wind because the rest of it [ __ ] got
snatched off from around its [ __ ]
neck just laying there dead is a [ __ ]
doornail
next day you come out there's two more
start driving down the work and you just
see him all over the place just being
the positive you know like [ __ ]
former stars and boy bands just
littering the [ __ ] highway and it's
[ __ ] over it's [ __ ] over so what
do you do then you got what you got New
Year's Eve coming up the worst [ __ ]
holiday of the year you know New Year's
Eve is for young people it's not for old
people you know that's when you know
you've hit a level of maturity is when
you can go to bed at like 10:00 o'clock
10:00 p.m. on New Year's Eve and you
didn't go out you didn't get drunk you
stayed away from those [ __ ] morons
you know I'll tell you what's a great
weekend to go out as the weekend after
New Year's Eve and all those guys and
people are still [ __ ] hungover and
they're still [ __ ] sick you know from
their overindulging cuz they don't know
how to drink then you then you head out
like I'll tell you what's it you know
it's gonna be a great night what's
what's New Year's Eve Friday night you
want to be a great night to go out
drinking Monday night that my friends
will be a great goddamn night if you're
an anti-social
[ __ ] prick like I am that's that's
where you want to go oh hey speaking of
which listen to this [ __ ] me and Paul
virzi we're coming down to the wire here
we're actually tied alright as of right
before this weekend we are tied alright
I gotta tell you something this week I
had a breakthrough on my gambling we
picked four games a week whoever wins it
in the end it's only a hundred bucks but
it's more just about the [ __ ] talk and
during the year so this year nobody has
gone undefeated yet all right so you're
talking 16 weeks of gambling 32 weeks
between the two of us nobody has gone
for know we've had you know a number of
three in once but nobody has gone for a
No
and Paul virzi actually did the
impossible what do we called the
unthinkable and the unimaginable the
unimaginable is going for a No
he did the unthinkable he went oh and
four so this week I don't know what I
was talking to one of nias uncles and he
was talking about going against public
opinion and there was this whole new
website and [ __ ] about going against
public opinion with your gambling and I
decided to take a little bit of that
alright cuz this is this is what I
realized the reason why I could never
break through three and one and get two
for know is because I kept picking
people that I thought were gonna win
every [ __ ] game and I know that
sounds crazy but to Gamblers it makes
sense you know when you don't have money
on the game you can actually sit there
and [ __ ] you know
just say you know what not only do I
think this team's gonna cover the spread
I think they're gonna win the [ __ ]
game but all of a sudden when you put
money on it your alligator arm it and
you you just start you know you get too
scared to take a [ __ ] chance at least
I did so this week I was like [ __ ] it
I'm taking a couple of chances here all
right I went safe at first
I picked Tampa over Seattle and their
Dockers wearing [ __ ] coaching staff
with Pete Carroll I said [ __ ] I'm
going with Tampa now that was one that I
was that was my plane at safe bet
and then I don't know I was looking at
Washington to Jacksonville and I was
like you know
it's in Jacksonville Jacksonville is
gonna win you know they're gonna win
this game they're gonna get the running
game going they're gonna [ __ ] run
over they got [ __ ] rex grossman
playing quarterback for washington it's
[ __ ] over but i don't know why I got
a feeling I got a feeling [ __ ]
Washington's gonna win this game just
because nobody thinks they're going to
so I said [ __ ] it
I bet on Washington you know and then
continuing that line of thought San
Diego was going into Cincinnati
Cincinnati is [ __ ] the bed the entire
[ __ ] year San Diego always plays well
in December they're a heckle heckle and
Jeckle of [ __ ] what'd he call it
Jekyll and Hyde [ __ ] team and I said
to hell with that I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm going with Cincinnati and lo and
behold yours truly went three and OH
yesterday three you know Paul virzi went
one and two he had the Sunday night game
but it got [ __ ] snowed out I am one
game up on him I'm sorry we're not tied
I am one game up on him alright so I
went three you know yesterday he went
one and two
no matter what happens tonight you know
if I lose my game he he wins this game
I'm gonna be up by two games with one
week to go all right but if I win
tonight and go for and over for no I
will have done the unimaginable I'll
done it and who do you think I took
tonight who would you take the spread is
two and a half Falcons at home playing
the Saints who do you like who do you
like 12 and 2 is that what uh is that
what the Falcons are Maddy ice at home
just given two and a half it's their
[ __ ] year I said [ __ ] it I'm taking
the Saints I took the Saints and the
points with Drew Brees sticking with
that line of thought of going against
the playing it's safe I think I don't
think the Falcons have been tested yet
this year and I just think that you know
this is just gonna be one of those
things that happens to a team like this
I still think they might be a year away
from doing something huge and this is
one of these games where I just think
they're gonna get a wake-up call like
okay we're good but we we but like we're
not like the Saints that actually have
gone through the whole thing I won the
Super Bowl that's why I took the Saints
I'm looking to go for a know Paul virzi
he's got the now Tuesday night game he
took the Minnesota Vikings getting 14
points and I'm telling you if I go for
an O and he goes one in three I'll pick
up three games I'll be up four games
with one week to go and we picked four
games all I have to do is [ __ ] win
one game
it's a goddamn extra point it's a chip
shot and I will get bragging rights for
the entire [ __ ] year and I will
really be excited about that and with
that seal there you go for although all
of you who are into the gambling aspects
of my life and with that somebody
actually came up with this awesome
theory about sports
this guy says bill I have I have a
theory about sports that tends to piss
people off especially women which makes
me think I'm onto something
and it's got nothing to do with the
unpredictability of sports
I think he's this is this theory is
basically why people like sports he said
it mainly applies to team sports some
individual sports too okay so here it is
it begins back in the day when armies
were in the field waiting to go into
battle an Army's objective was
essentially to conquer foreign lands and
rape women in order to celebrate the
glory of their race / culture and they
would train for battles by making up
games these games were based around
themes of land grabbing and raping in
this theory the ball football basketball
whatever represents the seed the goals
either posts or a hoop or a net
represents the opposing teams women
symbolizing either their legs up in the
air or their vag or their womb whatever
the opposing team represents the enemy
army and the objective of the game is to
get your seed past the opposition and
impregnate their women that's
essentially the theory and it's a bridge
version and it's why some sports are
like cracked and some are just who gives
a [ __ ]
when a sport is put together right it's
a primal source of highly addictive
goodness did you ever think somebody who
would like basically compare sports to
rape with then you know if you were
gonna do that you wouldn't think that
they would basically then just say yeah
and it's you think that they would be
trashing it not saying that it's a that
it's a form of highly addictive goodness
so there you go actually like that
theory I believe in that all that
subliminal [ __ ] you know and yeah I'll
go with that what do you guys think
about that theory am I the worst Merv
Griffin ever I have no studio audience
what do you guys think into the abyss
am I really gonna do another [ __ ] I
got it I got to be uh I gotta be
balanced here fair and balanced when it
comes to this Sports [ __ ] cuz it's
becoming too much sports I got a oh
here's one for you how about I tell you
I was I said I forgot I was gonna tell
you a story here
I took Cleo out we went outside for a
walk so she could do her business and
I'm walking up the street and I went
around the corner and Cleo is you know
she's going number one she's taking a
piss so I'm standing there right and I
looked and I see this guy as Cleo's
beginning to do her thing
his walking to his SUV like one of those
little mini ones like the Lexus sort of
one and I see him looking at me I just
sort of look back and didn't think
anything of it and Cleo's go in the
bathroom and I'm going that's a good
girl oh you're good I'm doing that [ __ ]
right slapping her on her [ __ ]
muscular thighs and you know she
finishes does a little Harlem shake you
know and then she foot we start [ __ ]
walking up the street and then I just
hit the guy down at the SUV he'd you off
something just say this
pick it up dude I'm like what
cuz dude pick it up
I go and I realized he thought she took
a [ __ ] what she didn't
she went number one I can't believe I
said that but I wanted to win the
argument I would be like she took a piss
and when she went number one and then
the guy just gets in his [ __ ] car
such a getness in his little SUV thing I
go what no sorry he goes I said sorry
yeah not as loud as you said that other
[ __ ] then he got in his car and he
[ __ ] drove away it's one thing I
[ __ ] hate about the West Coast is the
way they they confront you
the confrontation out here I don't know
why they do it
like back east it would have been like
hey dude [ __ ] NATO pick up your [ __ ]
you know out here that's always like I
don't know wonder this they was calling
you bro
hey bro what's up dude
pick it up dude just [ __ ] annoys the
[ __ ] out of me
just [ __ ] annoy I don't know that's
the only time it really bugs me being
out here is that that that surfer
[ __ ] way that they talk when they
they confront you bro what a douche and
you know what kills me is that that
affected that affected me the way I
interacted with people
you know for like the next four hours
I just had that playing and a loop in my
head was in my [ __ ] head everywhere I
went
you want paper or plastic you know just
it's you know follow me here pick it up
dude I'm just [ __ ] hearing that in my
head
and
what a dig you know what I mean
the proper way to do that is just to be
like excuse me did your dog just uh go
number two and then not on she went
number one and then okay I'm sorry it's
just lately people leaving okay that's
the way you do it let's go pick it up
dude [ __ ]
I wish I could train Cleo you know for
those you new to my podcast she is a
pitbull to just do a mock charge you
know they do that in the wild
I just wish it just teeth ah just
[ __ ] run just have that guy pee his
slacks a little bit and then right to
the point where he thought he was gonna
get his [ __ ] balls ripped off she
just stops on a dime it turns around and
his [ __ ] runs up the beautiful way
that she runs
I should take a video of my dog running
full-speed it's one of the most
beautiful things you're ever gonna see
it's literally you could make like one
of those Secretariat movies this [ __ ]
dog
she is shredded I like she she's awesome
in way she runs the level of power first
of all when she runs she gets like
excited right before she does and she
does this move was she sort of throws
her head back a little bit and just
throws herself full it's like it's like
a [ __ ] muscle car it's unbelievable
absolutely loved watching her run and if
I could just somehow train her to run
and scare the [ __ ] out of people who say
pick it up deed that would really make
me happy so that's what happened this
week and then I went inside then I ended
up getting into an argument with Nia cuz
I was just in a bad [ __ ] mood no
today now she got mad at me about
something else
she was really pissed at me this week I
don't what the [ __ ] you know for all
those deal I think it's cause I was
coming down off being off on the road
and she thought that I was gonna be a
dick and no matter how many times I tell
her that I have to you know I need a few
days to unwind like I literally have the
urge when I'm in the house to get up and
just get in the car and just start
driving around because I'm so in travel
mode and going going going going going
that it takes a [ __ ] minute so you
know I don't know I don't think I do
yoga or whatever the [ __ ] idea this
definitely seems to be causing a rift
but anyways I just remembered I was
gonna tell you oh I know last night I
went and I saw the fighter starring Mark
Wahlberg and Christian Bale and I can't
recommend that movie highly enough that
movie was [ __ ] awesome it was a movie
I wasn't going to
I'm like okay here we go Rocky all over
again but what saved it was it was Micky
Ward and I remember his fights and I'm
embarrassed to said I didn't see that
our Toro got he fight until years
afterwards I actually watched it on
YouTube and I remember Colin Quinn
coming into the cellar raving about that
fight
in fact there's two fights that I
remember that I was just like I have to
see this fight it was the Micky Ward
Arturo Gatti fight after hearing Colin
Quinn rave about it down at the Comedy
Cellar and the Diego crap corrales fight
was it Corrales Castillo fight satchel
was yes Diego I can't [ __ ] remember
she can tell I dip in and out of boxing
but uh that's a crap Corrales Castillo
their first [ __ ] fight is
unbelievable and Charlie Murphy flipped
out about that when he told me he almost
broke his foot at the end of that fight
well one of them's just you know knocked
out gets up and this trainer goes you
better [ __ ] get inside now cuz
everything I think I told this story
before you guys you better [ __ ] get
inside now and he put his mouthpiece in
him and he turned around they continued
around he [ __ ] knocks the other guy
technically knocks out the other [ __ ]
guy and I guess that got Charlie so
[ __ ] amped up he he stomped his foot
down on the floor and woke up his whole
family so those are the two fights but
anyways so this fight this this movie is
about Micky Ward's uh you know ascension
up to trying to win a championship and I
have to tell you man it is absolutely
phenomenal
I was rooting for like the Mark Wahlberg
character while he was fighting it was
[ __ ] awesome
maybe want to get in great shape and I
got to tell you I don't think I've ever
seen a movie where they did the Boston
accent better even just for that reason
even if you're not a sports fan you
gotta go see there and see the five
women that play his sisters they're
[ __ ] unbelievable and it reminded me
of this period in my life when I was
underage and I used to go out to these
bars in like Chelsea and all those awful
em towns north of Boston Malden Medford
Revere I used to go out to all of those
places cuz they didn't give a [ __ ] cuz
most of them were actually you know you
know people were doing coke it was the
80s and now some people were selling
coke so like alcohol just seemed like it
was a joke it's like somebody went up
there and asked for some juice so I
could actually get served with my
[ __ ] twelve-year-old boyish face and
those five women that you see in in in
that movie those are the kind of girls
that you ran into they will like 21
years old and they look like they were
40 they already had a kid and they were
jaded I can't explain it and it so
[ __ ] up was it was it was like a 20 25
minute ride from where I lived which was
a world away with no traffic of course
with traffic it took like a [ __ ] hour
to get there but uh yeah I just remember
shooting the [ __ ] with them to be oh
you're like smart but anyways those are
my two recommendations for this week get
uh get the book john bonham the
powerhouse behind Led Zeppelin by Mick
Bonham and go see the fighter I'm gonna
see True Grit this week and someone's
trying to talk me into going to see Tron
but I I just I could give a [ __ ] about
science fiction I've never been into it
I never liked Star Trek I like Star Wars
for maybe six months in my youth just
cuz everybody else liked it and I wanted
to fit in so I kind of got into by just
I don't give a [ __ ] I think those movies
are gay they're gay
alright there I said it alright you know
put on the afterburners I'm doing the
best I can hit warp speed and there's
stupid [ __ ] handshakes and and the
the aliens that they're friends with and
the gay names of the [ __ ] spaceships
that they ride around in and it's just
it's it's it's for nerds it's for people
who don't know how to get laid I don't
know that's not true but it just this
stereotype is true and speaking of which
I wanted to read this this overrated for
this week one
it's just reminded me of this somebody
wrote overrated Las Vegas somebody wrote
I'm tired of everybody going to Las
Vegas all the time they throw that [ __ ]
around like they're going like they're
getting a free trip to a Space Station
like yo anybody want to go to Vegas this
weekend like it's just the wildest
craziest place it's not Vegas [ __ ]
stinks it's really not that big a deal
there it's too hot the drive sucks how
do they not widen out that 14 it's
actually the 15 or whatever to be more
than two lanes yeah that's the highway
when you come back on Sunday it's it's a
[ __ ] nightmare always flying to Vegas
never drive unless you plan on leaving
at 2:00 in the [ __ ] morning he said
the other big thing I'm tired of with
Vegas is the media perception that it's
the craziest place on earth that you
never know what kind of nutty [ __ ] is
going on and it's like that every day of
the year you should just go wild there
go home with three strippers party like
crazy with your boys and wake up with
the most insane story ever it's like
that movie The Hangover it's like that
song waking up in Vegas from Katy Perry
whoo whoo yay let's go crazy well I'm
sorry to burst your bubble that doesn't
really happen there folks the 50s and
60s are over not much that that's hip
and happening goes on there you don't
see Sinatra and Dean coming out to deal
blackjack and drink with the common folk
unless you're bringing in sick a
six-figure salary it's actually pretty
mundane it's mostly full of sad old
people blowing the social security
Social Security checks on slot machines
and [ __ ] and lousy food and ugly
tourists with their stupid kids place
the place is like Disneyland with
gambling and god help you if you wake up
with the hangover it's generally 117
[ __ ] degrees out you walk out of your
hotel and go Vegas is not supposed to be
it's supposed to be this out-of-control
party place it's not you want a story
give Charles Manson a tab of acid and a
meat cleaver and let him loose on the
strip on a Friday night you'll have a
crazy
Vegas story [ __ ] that place all right
well sir I 100% agree and disagree all
at the same time see what you did is you
went there and you just looked at what
you saw like I did the first time I went
there I walked there and I was all
dressed up to do my shows like I was
gonna be in the [ __ ] Rat Pack and I
saw all these [ __ ] fat tourists with
their flip-flops and going wow
Vegas is dead it isn't you you just
don't know where to look first of all
you ever see those pretty girls playing
slots you know and you're like why is
that pretty girl all by herself playing
[ __ ] how come she doesn't have a
boyfriend
that's because she's a hooker sir you
want to have your crazy [ __ ] there
you go right there
did you like me first time I went to
Vegas I thought a hooker was you know
standing on a street corner snapping her
gum like that was a hooker all right but
no they're not supposed to be in the
casino but they look the other way
all right and I was actually at a bar
one time and Jimmy Dore told Dana I'm
sitting there hitting on this girl and
Bill and Jimmy finally came out goes
bill what the [ __ ] are you doing I was
like what this girl's hot he goes dude
you're hitting on a hooker and I was
like she's a hooker and he goes yes and
then all of a sudden it was like the
matrix I could see it and then I went oh
she's a hooker
there's a hooker there's a regular girl
regular girl hooker and all of a sudden
you could [ __ ] see it your problem is
you don't know how to see it yet put it
this way I just did a road gig with
somebody and he told me a story he went
to Vegas he won nine Grand walked up to
one of those girls said hey come here
and she stopped playing slots walked
right over to him he goes I want another
girl like you to suck my dick come up to
room whatever 1052 and they did and they
came up there and they were gorgeous and
they sucked his dick and he came on
their face and he won 9 grand that night
so there you go
it is a crazy awesome [ __ ] place
where [ __ ] can happen if you indulge all
right if you stand back like a [ __ ]
you know just [ __ ] all over the
place there yeah you're not gonna have a
good [ __ ] time it is cheesy it is
awful there are a bunch you know they
got malls there now they try to appeal
to families all of that [ __ ] definitely
goes on there but believe me all right I
mean I don't think you can go to
Foxwoods and just go hey you and you I
mean I you can probably do it but
they're gonna be old ladies it even
there I'm sure they have their hookers
all right but of course they do
but I'm telling you go there next time
you go there all right just look for
those pretty girls playing slots and you
will have and all of a sudden Vegas will
become they just can't show they can't
show that in the commercial
you know what was that Fox the Fox was
on but I do buy that baby to suck my
[ __ ] dick
remember that court I don't forget out
goes that whole thing about being at
Foxwoods like it's this crazy thing you
can't show somebody win nine you can
show that then winning nine grand but
you can't show that other part where he
goes hey you find another one just like
you whose dad didn't stick around so now
you suck dick for a living get another
one of those come back to my room and
then end the commercial bang boom Zhou
was he [ __ ] comes on their faces okay
you're supposed to read between the
lines all right so what I would do is I
would stop going to Vegas with the
[ __ ] nerds that you're going to Vegas
with you know I mean you're going to
Vegas dude you're trying to solve the
transportation problem you're talking
about the highways yeah you're not
looking at the right [ __ ] you know yes
Frank and Dean are not gonna be dealing
poke yeah they're dead they're dead okay
yes move on Ashton Kutcher's gonna be
there dress like James Bond taking I
[ __ ] hate those commercials I envy
that guy's career you know I really envy
that guy's career he's smart son of a
[ __ ]
most people do a hit [ __ ] sitcom and
then that's it he got into producing
very smart guy but I hate those [ __ ]
commercials with him sitting there with
the stupid cameras and everybody's just
enamored with him look at the guy with
the camera wait we all have cameras and
one in our phone
this really isn't that exciting so there
you go sir I know I trashed you but go
to Vegas again okay [ __ ] pony up the
[ __ ] 70 bucks and fly out there on
Southwest go down to the strip
okay
gamble hopefully you win if you don't
you know even if you don't just save a
little money and have a couple girls
blow you come on their face and I'm
guaranteeing you're gonna go home and a
smile even if you have to sit in that
traffic on the 15 hey listen I know
there's a lot of people listening to
this podcast that went to Vegas I want
to hear some stories and don't make them
up alright I want to hear some actual
goddamn stories okay and I'll see
through the [ __ ] ones unless you're
a really good storyteller okay because
the truth is in the details
we're gonna be talking [ __ ] like [ __ ]
Rex Ryan oh wait a minute the Jets lose
again this week that wasn't that funny
way isn't that funny it's almost like
exactly what I said was gonna happen
[ __ ] happened you know I know a lot
of you guys you probably can't remember
cuz you know you know nobody can
remember [ __ ] in this country like I
used to do a bit about that Geico lizard
how you know everybody loves that
[ __ ] thing and I just look at that
thing like that thing has no credibility
whatsoever when those commercials
started out he's like no I'm a gecko
alright get away from me [ __ ] you and
your insurance company then all of a
sudden he like [ __ ] sold out now he
sells the insurance that no one calls
him on the bull [ __ ] well this is my
[ __ ] Geico gecko lizard moment here's
Rex Ryan I'll play two clips this is Rex
Ryan on Hard Knocks back in August let's
hear what he has to say about his
football team which started my hatred of
the [ __ ] Jets here we go everybody
let's turn up the volume here we go
there you go could you hear that sorry I
just [ __ ] with the volume here ready to
crank that up alright that's what he
said we were beat every team if he
played our beds we could beat every
[ __ ] team and his [ __ ] League you
know the usual [ __ ] okay for those
you forgot all right now here's him
yesterday when they backed into the
[ __ ] playoffs like they did last year
here we go
oh jesus [ __ ] yeah what happened Rex
[ __ ] dope I swear to God was was i
was there's no reason for me to even
bring it up but i have to bring it up
okay that's the second major thing that
I was right about in football this year
and as much as you [ __ ] hate to admit
it you know I'm right I told you Peyton
Manning was [ __ ] overrated I told you
he's a regular-season statistical
juggernaut he threw a pick six to lose
the [ __ ] Super Bowl and he yet to get
[ __ ] for it his [ __ ] volume is way
too high I'm sorry let me bring this
down here he is yet to get [ __ ] for it
alright and I told you I don't I didn't
understand what the Jets were talking
about I didn't understand why they felt
like they were this [ __ ] you know was it
last year that they made the playoffs
because the Colts at half their [ __ ]
team wasn't it wasn't it that wasn't
last year is not how they got into the
[ __ ] playoffs then this year they
come in just talking all this [ __ ] now
look I'm not saying that they couldn't
go on any team in the NFL at this point
if you get hot in the end of December
you can actually go on a run and win the
[ __ ] Super Bowl like the Giants did
alright
that's another [ __ ] hilarious thing
the Giants losing again this week and
now they're questioning whether Tom
Coughlin is worthy to coach that team
that team that a mere two [ __ ] years
ago at three years ago beat an
undefeated team fourteen point underdogs
what did the game suddenly pass Tom
Coughlin by and two and a half [ __ ]
years New York this is the between New
York and Boston Boston jet is completely
100% negative and they'll give you a
little bit of positive in the second
they see negative they're like the curse
is back they're awful that way but New
York they kind of do the ESPN thing with
a hype [ __ ] through the roof and say
this is gonna be the greatest [ __ ]
thing ever and then when it doesn't
happen then they go the exact opposite
way and then it then and then just
somebody is the worst [ __ ] thing that
ever happened to the goddamn sport and
that's why me
yoga guys like Mark Sanchez who never
really did anything in [ __ ] college
foot what did he do he won the [ __ ]
Rose Bowl with that team that had won
the national championship I know there's
a turnover of players but give me a
break
Matt Lionheart did more than that
[ __ ] guy and he's not even in
football anymore I think he's playing in
like the [ __ ] CF of CFL right so
there you go people but I will tell you
this I I do back Rex Ryan on his foot
fetish video I don't think there's
anything [ __ ] wrong with that he's
got a foot fetish he made a video I
totally agree with him it is a private
matter and you know the guy loves his
wife that's what I got out of it I
didn't think he was a weirdo I think
that was just one of those classic
[ __ ] examples of every yet buddy out
there throwing sticks and stones and all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] when we all have these
skeletons in our in our closet huh does
anybody else want to turn over their
[ __ ] hard drive their computer hard
drive and let the FBI go through it and
look at all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
you've looked at on the Internet give me
a [ __ ] break I'm a freak just like
him I'm not in defeat you know some of
the horrific [ __ ] that I've looked at on
the Internet I'm gonna [ __ ] judge
this guy then the end they he kissed
kept going it's a personal matter I'm
not gonna talk about it you're gonna ask
me 16 ways to Sunday it's a personal
matter and I was like that's exactly
right Rex it's exactly [ __ ] right
it's your own [ __ ] life it's a
personal matter I'm not talking about it
go [ __ ] yourselves I don't give a [ __ ]
that it's on the internet it's none of
your goddamn business watch the video if
you want I don't give a [ __ ] then they
go can you at least talk about your wife
and he goes yeah what can I say I've
been with them for 23 years I love her
she's awesome I was like you know what
this guy's a great dude and I realized
that I was wrong saying that he was
gonna make an attempt on his life one
day because he he is because he has a
great woman in his life and that's
that's what's holding that man together
and told you
I told you once psycho can spot another
psycho from across the room so god bless
Rex Ryan and his [ __ ] foot fetish 23
years he still [ __ ] got the hots for
his wife he's making freaky videos but I
thought that was his [ __ ]
gave me hope that's what it did gave me
hope I don't think that guy's a freak at
all and it's like that tiger would [ __ ]
and everybody sat dead judging him
people are full of [ __ ] you know just
listen to that quiet voice in the back
of your head that's calling you a
hypocrite when you're at the dinner
party trash and Tiger Woods you know
when you think of some of the [ __ ] that
you've you know that you rubbed one out
to your wife's sister
what if that ever got out what if there
was [ __ ] video with that you [ __ ]
[ __ ] rubbing one out to your wife's
[ __ ] sister
and we could see the [ __ ] video
that's playing in your goddamn head
really you're gonna judge this guy cuz
he's in two feet I don't judge him for
that [ __ ] I do judge him for being a
[ __ ] talkin jackass who sounds like one
of my [ __ ] buddies at a [ __ ] sports
bar I will trash him for that
so with that who do you guys think is
gonna win the Super Bowl cuz I for one
have no [ __ ] idea I have no faith in
my team I don't even know who they are
anymore they let my Patriots they're
like a drug addict you know are they
clean
are they clean this week and they're
gonna play they're gonna play [ __ ]
defense are they they just gonna I don't
know I don't know and I don't like that
that we basically should have lost to
the [ __ ] Packers but Aaron Rodgers
was out and even then we still should
have [ __ ] lost but they didn't manage
the clock right and you know we lost to
the Jets once Jets could come in and
beat us they could still come in and
beat us in our own [ __ ] place I mean
that's the kind of way football is right
now so which is why I don't understand
the whole Rex Ryan [ __ ] talking that's
what it was about so there you go let's
see let's move on to something else here
let's go with advice bill hey I just
want to write you and say I got let it
go for Christmas I really needed it - my
girlfriend dumped me on Christmas Eve so
you know my Christmas sucked but your
DVD really helped me out a lot last
night I know what you say about breakups
six weeks of pain and then it gets
easier I said we were together for nine
months and out of the blue on Christmas
Eve she called me up and said she needed
time for herself and her daughter
that makes it tough - I got really close
to her kid here's my question what's the
worst breakup you've ever had and have
you ever have you ever been dumped over
the holidays all right there's a number
of things going on here sir first of all
that's a real honest move on her part
you know that whole [ __ ] thing where
you just go through a Christmas cuz you
don't want to hurt somebody's feelings
you know it's there's no good time for a
break if she just could not go through
the phone enos a celebrating Christmas
with you when she knew she was gonna
[ __ ] drop the other shoe all over
that [ __ ] expression goes so I gotta
give her props for being [ __ ] honest
but uh and then also dude you know you
can do better than hooking up with some
chick who already has a kid and I hate
to be mean I'm not trying to trash women
out there who have [ __ ] kids in this
single in that type of [ __ ] but I'm
trying to give this guy something
positive all right you know it's like
yeah you got it you got it down dude six
weeks it's gonna suck this is what you
want to do just go to the gym go to the
[ __ ] Jew this is what women do women
[ __ ] cry it out with their friends to
get it out of their system and then they
go to the [ __ ] gym and the next time
you run into them they want you to have
that moment why the [ __ ] did I dump you
what guys we never do that what do we do
we get [ __ ] drunk get a big fat
[ __ ] John Travolta head and then go
out and try to bang some skank at 3:00
in the morning don't do that to yourself
all right just know it's gonna hurt and
[ __ ] you know go spoon with your
pillow and cry it out and then go to the
[ __ ] gym put on some music that's
gonna motivate you go see that movie the
fighter all right go get [ __ ]
motivated we'll do that [ __ ] and then
then just go out and just start hitting
on chicks that are completely way out of
your [ __ ] league and you know just go
talk some [ __ ] and then you got the out
I'm not ready to be in a relationship I
got broken up with on Christmas [ __ ]
Eve I'm not even trying to talk to women
you do that you [ __ ] do the reverse
cell you backing up they're walking
towards you dick that's how you do it
you know you'll get a sympathy [ __ ]
or something just open your [ __ ]
mouth don't be negative
keep them [ __ ] laugh and spin a
couple of plates something will happen
for you next thing you know I'd be like
wow dad then I almost get involved with
the [ __ ] I was thinking about getting
married to some woman already had a
[ __ ] kid you know who's never really
gonna consider you her dad it's gonna
have a bunch of issues and her dad's not
gonna be around
when when her daughter goes through her
her [ __ ] years because she's trying to
find another father figure you don't to
be around for that [ __ ] you did all
right
it's anyways he said here's my question
what's the worst breakup you've ever had
and have you ever been dumped over the
holidays worst breakup I ever had was I
broke up with this girl who then ended
up stalking me she told me she was
pregnant
I believed her I got back into her life
and then obviously I've realized you
know when she was never showing that she
wasn't pregnant yeah I had one of those
just a complete [ __ ] psycho would
stalk me at my day job and all that she
was a [ __ ] nightmare
I had one of those and I've ever been
dumped over the holidays no I haven't
I've mainly been the person
that's dump people but I did get dumped
the [ __ ] that I get dumped it was in a
September
yeah I was September September
yeah
yeah and it was it sucked it was [ __ ]
brutal and I did the dumb [ __ ] I went
out and I drank and I didn't that that's
you know something that's the basis of
my advice that I give you guys when you
men are women when you go through a
breakup is just allow yourself to know
that it's gonna suck yes it's gonna suck
yes you're gonna come home the phone
isn't gonna ring and you're gonna be
sitting there trying to put the pieces
back together going what the [ __ ] that I
used to do with all this extra time and
just go through that is the best thing
that I can tell you and [ __ ] embrace
it and just know it's gonna hurt and
that's the best advice I can give me
because I did not do that
the worst thing you want to do is go out
start booze and try to bang somebody
else and then go into a [ __ ] rebound
relationship I did that a couple of
times it's [ __ ] brutal it's not what
the [ __ ] you want to do so I know we had
a couple questions somebody I keep
getting questions about on the Opie and
Anthony show Patrice O'Neal and Kevin
Hart talked about this diss thrashing
that I took and was a long [ __ ] time
ago I haven't listened to the audio yet
just look it up on YouTube I'm sure they
have the audio up without even listening
to the audio whatever they said is more
than truth it was an epic 50 [ __ ]
minute thrashing that I took what the
[ __ ] was a story st at the Comedy Cellar
alright how do i corner what do I start
this the Yankees were playing the Braves
in the [ __ ] World Series and I guess
there was news these groups of people
from Atlanta wanted to we're gonna take
that's right they've taken two buses to
Yankee Stadium to go to the game and
they wanted a comedian to perform on the
bus on the way to the stadium alright
which obviously is the most nightmare
gig ever they were gonna pay you like
500 bucks and give you a World Series
ticket all right so the the gig was
offered to me like s he was like who's
the two biggest sports fans I know a
down here so she offered
and actually don't have enough money in
the bank where they'll actually consider
doing this so she approached me in Jim
Norton about the gig so me and Norton
are just talking about it going to this
is gonna be the worst [ __ ] gig ever
but you get to go to the World Series
and we were both thinking about it so
the next day over 24 hours Norton
finally just goes [ __ ] that I'm not
doing it so I was gonna do it I was like
[ __ ] them it's not gonna be that bad
a gig that's the thing about it it
wouldn't have been that bad a gig
I basically was gonna get paid to go to
a World Series game and to get paid to
do what the [ __ ] I was gonna do anyways
which is trash the Yankees all the way
up to Yankee Stadium that's the only
part about the story that's [ __ ] is
them talking about what a horrific gig
it would have been it would have been a
[ __ ] cakewalk compared to those
college gigs I did where they didn't
have a [ __ ] microphone and they stand
you in a hallway it would be a bunch of
drunk fans excited to see their team
that didn't have a shot and [ __ ] hell
of beating the Yankees and all I was
gonna do was tell him what a [ __ ] Jeter
was for [ __ ] 30 minutes a half-hour
[ __ ] set would have been a joke
all I have to do is trash the Yankees
the whole [ __ ] way up I get 500 bucks
and I get a World Series ticket in the
second I get off I can screw I can leave
those guys I get to go to a World Series
game and [ __ ] Yankee Stadium so I'm
like I'm gonna [ __ ] do it right so I
didn't know that Jim had said that he
wasn't going to do it so we're sitting
down there at the table down at the
cellar and it's starting up everybody's
giving each other [ __ ] so I start giving
Norton [ __ ] about whatever about his
chin list face his little ears or
whatever [ __ ] awful hooded sweatshirt
that he was wearing and then I got him
with a couple of jabs and he felt the
overhand right coming and he needed to
stop it he just goes whatever bus boy
and it was like EF Hutton everybody
[ __ ] stopped and went what why did
you just call him busboy and I
immediately was like he's gonna do it
too and somehow Jim got out of it and
just he literally threw me under the bus
and then they found out I was doing the
gig and it just so happened that night
at all the [ __ ] the big boys where
there was Patrice Norton was there Kevin
Hart rich Voss Keith Robinson right
[ __ ] there
the Tyson Holyfield George Foreman all
of that and I'm standing there like
[ __ ] Tex Cobb and I took a 15 minute
I took a headlining set killing standing
ovations set of [ __ ] for doing that gig
and I was still gonna do it I was still
gonna do it even after the [ __ ]
trashing because I'm thinking I'm going
to [ __ ] World Series I don't give a
[ __ ] you know and Patrice was trashing
me and I didn't give a [ __ ] what he said
his advice I never would have listened
to because Patrice was one of the
biggest [ __ ] when it came to
performing hell gigs like when we used
to do colleges this guy used to book us
on colleges and would be me him and
Robert Kelly or me him and Norton or
whatever and this dude never wanted to
go on first because first sucks because
you gotta warm up the crowd and he never
wanted to go on last cuz he had to
follow the other 2x he always wanted to
go on second and he and then he go on
second and he would go over his [ __ ]
time like the selfish [ __ ] that he is
and so just a guy you know this guy this
guy [ __ ] uh this guy retires from
comedy every two weeks when he sees a
hack kill on stage I don't give a [ __ ]
what he thinks but it was it wasn't
until the end when he actually looked at
me when the thrashing was over and he
said Bill he goes I will stand in front
of that bus don't do that gig I'll buy
you a ticket to the World Series don't
do that and then I was sitting there
going like wow this is actually like
he's not even joking right now he's
trying to tell me for the love of God
have a little bit of self [ __ ] worth
and he [ __ ] that was the thing after a
50 minute thrashing isn't as
embarrassing as that was nothing was
worse than the shame of him
telling me that I could actually afford
a World Series ticket at that point I
wasn't really even thinking that so I
decided I in that moment I I decided not
to do the gig which I don't think came
out on the Opie and Anthony show they
think I did the gig I never did the gig
and I actually passed it off to another
comedian who was further down the ladder
than I was and he didn't even ask me but
I always made a promise that I would
never say who did the gig and I don't
know next time I go on Opie and Anthony
I'll talk to the dude who actually did
the gig and see if he wants to call in
and talk about the gig but that's the
only I haven't listened to the audio yet
but whatever jokes that they said there
were some classic ones I remember
Patrice saying hey Bill when they bring
you up are you gonna come out of the
bathroom are you gonna walk up up those
little stairs that and then also me
finishing my set going hey thanks a lot
and then I sit down on the bus seat and
then look over my shoulder and shake
everybody's hands as they go to get off
the bus was I gonna [ __ ] hold the you
know the bus intercom thing would I do
it over that yeah it yet all that and
this would kill me they had jokes for
fifty [ __ ] minutes all that was true
but I never did the gig I never did the
gig and and I still maintained it
wouldn't have been that bad of a [ __ ]
gig it wouldn't but would have been a
joke bill get on a bus for a half an
hour and trash the Yankee's do you think
he can do that we'll give you 500 bucks
in a World Series ticket absolutely I
would have been drinking with them at
any time I ran out of [ __ ] this talk
about the Yankees you just look out the
bus Hey look at the tits on that [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they'd all go nuts
all I had to do is support the South and
the Civil War there was so many
different ways that I could've done it
would've been a [ __ ] cakewalk a [ __ ]
cakewalk and I didn't end up doing it I
didn't end up doing it which actually
was better cuz the first time I went to
a World Series ended up being uh I went
to Game two with 2004 that boring-ass
World Series was exciting cuz we finally
won it so there you go so that that is
the story yes they trashed the [ __ ] out
of me but I never did the gig I was
shamed out of doing it and I gave it to
another comedian who will remain
nameless actually you know what here let
me then we do a little cross promotion
here I will reveal the name the next
time I do the Opie and Anthony show if
they still give a [ __ ] if they still
give a [ __ ] if the story has legs as
they say in the business so uh so there
you go there's that [ __ ] story
alright and I'll try to remember the
name of this podcast in case he gets
somebody a couple more questions about
it and I'll just say refer to the
podcast on December 27th alright YouTube
videos of the week um these are all
gonna be on the mm podcast com you can
watch all of these the so-called white
man somebody sent a great video of
somebody they the dude didn't have a
microphone but he was he was talking
about all how the white man you know
he's [ __ ] with everybody the way he
twisted up religion and all that [ __ ]
which is totally true but in the end he
goes cuz God is actually a black man so
basically it's like everything that
white people just did I am now gonna do
from my perspective which is the one
thing that I've learned when I being on
the road that everybody is the same and
it includes the bad [ __ ] you know that
liberal thought that you know everybody
is to say but it's only good [ __ ]
everybody has the ability to be a
scientist to be a doctor you know a
[ __ ] teacher everybody has yes yes
they do and they also have the ability
to be a [ __ ] CEO at Enron to be a
rapist and to be a [ __ ] serial killer
and all the bad [ __ ] everything to be a
war criminal a [ __ ] dictator
everybody that is not that is not an
exclusive
white thing does white people get blamed
for evil like we're the only evil ones
in the planet we are not we are just the
best at it
we are the Michael Jordan's of evil
everybody I challenge your race to top
my race with the evilness but you got it
in you you got to know that all right
you got to know that you have it in you
the same way you have it in you to be a
doctor or a lawyer or a teacher you also
have it in you to be a complete [ __ ]
sociopath so there's there's my [ __ ]
two cents alright clumsy reporter knocks
down I don't know how to say Jenga tower
any one of this Leaning Tower of Pisa F
V a tow rope failed this is somebody
towing their friend's car down the
street with a rope and it doesn't go
that well Merry Christmas [ __ ] need i
say more Harvard sailing team boys will
be girls and on from Funny or Die drunk
history and I think that's it
I think that's it for the podcast this
has been a very long one a gift card
really quick let me read this gift card
dude what is your deal with gift
certificates this guy right here is the
exact reason why I don't like gift
certificates would you rather get some
shitty sweater or boxer briefs from your
aunt or brother-in-law or a gift
certificate from Amazon or Best Buy well
you could buy something you actually
like hey [ __ ] why don't you not go
out and buy a shitty sweater a boxer
briefs
see you on creative [ __ ] maybe he should
give out a gift card that's why I don't
like it because you know it's like
you're out there and you buy somebody a
great [ __ ] gift and then they go eh
you go shop for yourself [ __ ] it's
lazy that's why that's why I don't
[ __ ] like it
I don't mind it if I get if we both
agree to get each other gifts artifical
I don't mind that when I'm out there
actually trying to buy you a [ __ ]
cool ass gift and you come up do you
just write me a check you know
like I'm some drunk [ __ ] gonna say your
[ __ ] son raped somebody and you're
running for Senate and you need the
problem to go away that's why I don't
like it so go [ __ ] yourself
alright revenge I gotta read this
quickly here which is gonna cause all
kinds of problems alright I went to a
local junior college wait a second I
just jumped in too far this maybe is
more of a story of lashing out than
revenge I actually think this is a story
of revenge and I like this story because
this is I bawled eyeball even though it
was a little elf Samuelsson here my
senior year I dated a beautiful
underclassmen she was my first love and
first lay we dated through the summer
after graduation I went on to a local
junior college the next year Jesus
Christ shop class guy right here alright
we were still dating when school started
up the next year I had a lot of friends
that were still in high school and one
of my best friends told me that he
started seeing my girlfriend hanging out
at school with another good friend of
mine my girlfriend was acting shady so I
knew something was up four years during
the football season a big group of guys
would get together on Sundays and play a
game of tackle football this guy who was
seen with my girlfriend was among the
guys that showed up to play with me
thought to play with the everybody me
and this guy this other guy you name it
all names I'm trying to skip over the
names here
me and this other guy would normally
play QB so we would be the two to pick
teams each week the quarterback on the
other team was also a good friend of
mine the friend of mine look all these
[ __ ] names hey the friend of mine who
was messing with my girl didn't know
that I was aware that he and my girl had
been flirty at school so I asked my
buddy the QB on the other team to pick
this douche who's messing with my girl
and at some point during the game
send him in on a hard v and in I don't
know what that is that like a post patty
guess it's a crossing pattern and lead
him high he's basically going over the
middle he's gonna throw him throw the
ball high and just out of his reach
leaving this guy completely exposed so
anyways he goes a few plays into the
game they come out of the huddle and my
buddy the QB on the other team gives me
a look
he goes I called it to one to defense
Jesus Christ just like them the most
professional pickup football game ever
so I bring in the nickel defense I had
to call a timeout because we had too
many men on the field I called it to one
to defense and took the short right zone
the ball was snapped and this douchebag
who's flirting with my girl came off the
line took a hard left and in slow motion
ran into my zone i delay 1 or 2 seconds
and begin the path to the collision my
buddy led him perfect so he had to pick
up a little speed to get to the ball and
he extended both arms to the sky and of
course he's looking back at the
quarterback to Jesus Christ the second
the ball hit his hands I bury my
shoulder into his stomach I grabbed the
back of his knees and I pull up and
drive him into the ground now I can't
define the word squelch but he
definitely let out a sound that own that
I can only describe as squelched
yeah really that that word makes it
sound like you actually hit a really
ripe melon the entire field erupted with
a holy [ __ ]
My Little League coach would have given
me two stars on my helmet for this
[ __ ] hit I felt good about it for
about three
seconds and the room then there were
more setting I feel bad to this day for
setting this guy up the way I did it
took a few minutes for him to get up but
he was fine I don't know about karma but
a few weeks later this dude that he
drilled into the ground was banging his
ex-girlfriend and I met my rebound that
I dated for the next 5 years she turned
out to be the devil herself I might not
believe in God but I've hooked up I've
looked the devil in her evil eye as I
shot a load into her evil [ __ ] Jesus
Christ um I don't think karma got you I
think he was gonna bang her no matter
what and I think he got a nice shot in
there it was a little cheesy that you
had your friends set him up but but [ __ ]
him that's what he gets that's your girl
he shouldn't have been doing that he was
wrong you were right and as far as karma
goes I view karma is like what's that
[ __ ] will you look at the Stars to see
if you're gonna get a chicken sandwich
that day what do you call it is it
astrology astronomy is the study of
stars astrology yeah like I don't
believe in astrology you know and
anybody who does you go okay you believe
in it I can you just go what's your sign
and then they tell you this sign and
then read somebody else's horoscope if
they're a gem and I read a Taurus and go
alright how does that pertain to your
life the being okay it means death it's
in this and go yes see that was Taurus
so there you go you can [ __ ] it this
is so vague you can attribute it to
anything something wonderful is gonna
happen today just be careful you don't
close it off or it won't happen so then
if something wonderful doesn't happen
you then walk well I I must have been
closed off I need to be more open and
then they get off scot-free right I feel
the same way about karma karma is
something that if you there's ups and
downs in life okay and if you just
you're waiting for something bad to
happen something Bad's gonna [ __ ]
happen no matter how good you are
something Bad's gonna [ __ ] happen
you know buy brand-new pair of sneakers
someone's gonna step on him you know
you're like why I starve a [ __ ] die I
starve I sponsor a starving child I
don't [ __ ] around I'm a good guy why did
somebody step on my sneaker because the
world is full of [ __ ] it's impossible
not to run into him you know I think
karma exists if you believe in it I
think if you don't believe in karma like
you you were never really you don't
really have any bad [ __ ] happen to you
there you go that's what I think about
karma I am an hour in 17 [ __ ] minutes
into this podcast ladies and gentlemen I
think it's time to attend the podcast
here I hope you enjoyed it I hope you
guys all had a very Merry Christmas a
happy Kwanzaa Happy Hanukkah or maybe
you just said [ __ ] it all and I'm gonna
take a few days off and that is it
that's the podcast please please oh
please well the shows are all sold out
so go scalp a ticket i speaking of Jim
Norton the man who threw me under the
bus and it took him 10 years to make up
for it actually made up for it when he
put me on down-and-dirty and he hooked
me up with Opie and Anthony but let's
say I don't count those you know cuz I'm
into astrology he hooked me up again
with this awesome gig that he does every
year at the [ __ ] would have screw
this up down in Atlantic City and this
year he was like you know what why
should I take it all for myself why
don't I share it with some friends and
I'm doing a show at the the [ __ ]
casino down there in Atlantic City why
don't I know the name of it [ __ ]
Internet doesn't work on my bedroom
whatever it's [ __ ] sold out anyways
but it's me Jim Norton Jim Breuer and
Dave Attell it's gonna be a [ __ ]
unbelievable night of three shows if you
can't make that if you didn't get
tickets it's because it's already sold
out my next gig is I'm gonna be in
Dallas Texas on the final weekend in
January the week of the NFL Pro Bowl the
27th 28th 29th I believe that weekend
I'm gonna be at the improv in Dallas
I'm sorry 28 29 and 30 improv in Dallas
Texas please come out I got a brand new
killer hour of stuff anything else
Oh rats
fans are baseball fans and generally
should check this out Steve Gorman from
the Black Crowes has its own podcast of
course I don't have the [ __ ] link
because I'm an idiot
Steve Gorman sports SGS is the name of
the podcast great podcast he interviews
Kevin Youkilis and Kevin G he just he's
got a great interview style where he
just gets the other person to relax and
he starts talking about just all kinds
of cool [ __ ] favorite ballparks favorite
restaurants if you're into sports
performance-enhancing drugs
Petros should he be in the Hall of Fame
or not having Entourage 'as team
chemistry all the [ __ ] you want to and
it's great it goes on for well over an
hour and it's totally [ __ ]
entertaining highly recommend that
podcast keeps getting better every time
I hear it and that's it that's the
podcast for this week I'm going to be
interviewing Nick Swardson this week for
a very special podcast and I am also
going to the Rose Bowl on New Year's Day
and I am gonna be stone [ __ ] sober
this year I know you guys are all booing
right now because you want to hear the
happy drunk stories where I'm sick of
being a drunk on that day I would like
to remember like I went to a game and
Sanchez played the USC Penn State I went
to that game and I had never even heard
of Sanchez that's how drunk I was they
think that I could have been live booing
that guy I wouldn't made a difference he
they still [ __ ] killed the they still
killed Penn State all right whatever
that's the podcast for this week god
bless all you have a great week don't
take any [ __ ] in a go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
all day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]